ام
اهلا بكم طالب رئيس اقليم كردستان العراق
مسعود البرزاني برلمان الاقليم بوضع قانون
للمفوضيه مستقله للانتخابات من اجل
الاعداد لاجراء استفتاء حول تقرير المصير
في المنطقه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
محورين اذن مطالبات باتخاذ خطوات باتجاه
تقرير المصير في كردستان العراق فما هي
امكانيه تحققه وما الاثار التي يمكن ان
تترتب على ذلك داخليا واقليميا
دعا رئيس كردستان العراق مسعود البرزاني
برلمان الاقليم الى وضع قانون انشاء
مفوضيه مستقله للانتخابات خاصه بالمنطقه
تعمل على اجراء استفتاء حول تقرير المصير
واضاف البرزاني ان المناطق التي دخلت
اليها قوات البيشمركه لن تنسحب منها لانها
مناطق كرديه واكد ايضا ان الدول التي لا
تؤيد الاقليم في مساعيه لا ت عاديه ايضا
لم يحدث للاكراد امر كهذا منذ نهايه
امبراطوريه وصفت طويلا بالرجل المريض
البرزاني اخيرا في صوره ما يصدر الاكراد
نحو لحمهم المبتغى خطوه واحده يعرف انها
شائكه تقربه من حلم طال انتظاره يجدها
سانحه فيطلب من برلمان الاقليم تشكيل لجنه
انتخابيه مستقله لاجراء استفتاء على تقرير
المصير قبل ذلك التقى الرجل وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وابلغه بعباره واضحه انه اصبح من
الصعب جدا تخيل العراق كيانا واحدا ولدى
لقائه وزير الخارجيه البريطاني قرر امامه
ان الماده مائه واربعين من الدستور
العراقي لم تعد موجوده وتلك تتعلق ب كركوك
والمناطق المتنازع عليها و بدخول قوات
البيشمركه اليها فان واقعا جديدا حدث
بالنسبه البرزاني الغي بموجبه فكره
التنازع وغلب عليها فكره ضم المدينه التي
يعتبرها البعض القدس الاكراد دستوريا
يعتبر اقليم كردستان العراق اقليم اتحادي
اي لا يجوز له الانفصال عن الوطن الام لكن
خلافات المالكي مع البرزاني ال جاءت
الاخيره سابقا الى التهديد باعاده النظر
في العلاقه مع بغداد وبدات حكومه كردستان
بعد ذلك بالتصرف بالنفط بيع وتصدير ا وذلك
على خلاف اتفاق يقضي بان تقوم الحكومه
العراقيه ببيع النفط على ان يحصل الاقليم
على نسبه ثابته من الدخل الاجمالي للبلاد
و بسيطره البرزاني على كركوك التي تعوم
على بحيره من النفط فان الاقليم سيصبح
اكثر قوه واستقلاليه ولكن دون ذلك تحديا
تسع اب فالاقليم يقع في وسط مثل ثمن
الكبيره التي تخشى فكره استقلال الاكراد
في منطقه هي الا غنيه بالنفط والنزاعات
القوميه المضطربه منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الاولى في اقليم كردستان مطوق
بايران شرقا وتركيا شمالا وسوريا من الغرب
وتبلغ مساحته نحو ثمانيه عشره في المائه
من مساحه العراق ولديه من السكان ما يزيد
عن الخمسه ملايين نسمه واداريا لديه
محافظاته الكبرى والاهم تجربته في اداره
حكم ذاتي ازدهرت فيه احوال سكانه
بالمقارنه مع تدهور اوضاع نظرائهم في بقيه
مدن العراق ناهيك عن تقديم هما نموذج
لبقيه الاكراد في المنطقه هبت رياح هم تسع
والاهتمام ها على وعوره الطريق نحو تحقيق
الهدف
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا حيث ينضم
الينا من اربيل عبد الحكيم خسرو الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ومن انقره انور شفيق
الكاتب الصحفي سيد خسره ابدا معك بسؤالك
عن موقف البرزاني اليوم هل جاء ردا على ما
قاله المالكي امس حين قال عباره تقرير
المصير غير موجوده في الدستور
كلام السيد المالكي لكن كان جزء من برنامج
وضعه السيد البرزاني الى اعطاء دور كبير
للبرلمان البرلمان اقليم كل وسام باعتباره
مرجعيه القرارات السياسيه المصيريه وبعد
عشر حزيران بعد سقوط الموصل كان هناك
الكثير من الاحداث اللي كان مفروض من
السيد رئيس الاقليم انه يزور البرلمان
وامام نواب الشعب يقول ما يدور اه في اه
السياسه الداخليه والاقليميه وما هي
الحقيقه وراء هذه التحولات والتغيرات
السريعه فاتصور انه حتى التصريحات السابقه
فيما يتعلق بانتهاء الماده مائه واربعين
وبقاء قوات البيشمركه او وضع او الانتهاء
من حدود اقليم كردستان ومن ثم الاستفتاء
على تقرير المصير هذه كلها من الامور اللي
كان الواجب انه
اه امام البرلمان واه يرجع يرجع اه اه
اساس القرار الى البرلمان باعتبار هي قضيه
مصيريه والامر الاخر يتعلق ب اه ال القضاء
نهائيا على كل ال اه التكهنات حول مواقف
الاحزاب الكردستانيه من اه مواقف رئاسه
الاقليم باعتبار انه بعض الاحزاب
الكردستانيه وخاصه الاتحاد الوطني الكل
سابقا كان قد اصدر ايضا بيانا فيما يتعلق
موقفه من الماده مائه واربعين من الدستور
العراقي ومن العمليه السياسيه في العراق
اذن هذا كله قطع الطريق امام اه امام هذه
التكهنات ومن ثم الرجوع الى برلمان اقليم
كردستان باعتباره المرجع الاساسي ل اه اه
تقرير القرارات المصيريه بخصوص اقليم
كردستان ومن ثم وضع الاليات والخطوات
الضروريه للتعامل مع مستقبل الدوله
العراقيه ومستقبل اقليم كردستان فيما
يتعلق ب اه اه خطوات الاستقلال الاستفتاء
ومن ثم اعلان الاستقلال عن الدوله
العراقيه وتشكيل دوله مستقله ومن ثم
التفاوض معه يعني على الرغم من من من من
اه قوله بان هذا نوعا من ال من المخاطره
لكن برلمان اقليم كردستان هو الذي يكون
مسؤولا عن عن القرارات الى مساله المخاطره
هذه لكن قبل ذلك سيدي رفيق الكاتب الصحفي
من انقره برزاني قال ان الدول التي لا
تؤيد الاقليم في مساعيه لا ت وعاديه ايضا
يا ترى ما موقف تركيا
تركيا كانت دائما تتصرف
باعتبارها شقيقا
لاداره برزاني وفي السنوات القليله
الماضيه العلاقات بين انقره والبارزاني
تحسن تتصل مستويات عاليه جدا و انقر من
خلال اظهارها دعمها للبرزاني سمحت تصدير
النفط الكردي الى الاسواق العالميه وهذه ا
مائه كبيره من جانب تركيا انا شخصيا
اه دائما شعرت وان الاخوه الكرديه التركيه
عملت من اجلها منذ ثلاثين عاما وانا سعيد
بهذه النتيجه وحقيقه ان
الشعب الكردي يتطلع قدما الان الى مصير
اكثر اشراقا امر يسعدنا جميعا في انقره
لكن ما لا يريده الاتراك هو ان يكون
الوجود التركي الكردي عفوا مهدد
بالخطر لان الحديث عن
الاستقلال وتقرير المصير بات يلوح في
الاجواء واصبح حقيقه
لو تفكك العراق ماذا سيفعل الاكراد عليهم
ان يلجؤوا الى العالم والى تركيا والى
انقره ليقولوا ان هناك نار حارقه هل
تريدوننا ان نعيش فيها ام ننقذ انفسنا
بالبقاء خارجها لكن بالطبع هناك مساله
اخرى ايضا وهي هل يستطيع الكرد من خلال
اعلان الاستقلال ان يبقوا انفسهم بمناى عن
هذه النار وبعيدا عن ها في وقت تلتهم
نيران العراق برمته هذا هو سؤال يستحق
الاجابه وهو تحد كبير ساعود اليك عن موقف
تركي تحديدا سيد شفيق اه سيد خسره اه
السيد شفيق
تقريبا يعني وجه اليك كسؤال ا يعني حتى لو
اه تحقق الاستقلال انت قلت هو مخاطره
وهنالك دول تعارض على راسها الولايات
المتحده قالت نفضل ان يبقى العراق متحدا
وقويا في ظل هذه الظروف طيب هذه المخاطر ه
هل انتم واثقون من ان يكون تستطيعون خوضها
ماذا عن موقف الولايات المتحده
والاتجار انكم تستغلون مصيبه العراق الان
حتى ت فتوه حتى تشارك في تفتيت
لا طبعا ال النظام السياسي بالعراق هو
الذي ساهم في تفتيت الدوله العراقيه لان
ال الثوره السنيه في العراق على الرغم من
دخول داعش وكثير من الفصائل اه وركوب هذه
الفصائل الموجه موجه ال الاعتراضات في هذه
المناطق لكن اعتقد ان ال قد لم يكونوا
سببا في تهميش المناطق السنيه بالعراق
والكل لم يكن سببا في اه تاجيل او تجميد
الماده مائه واربعين كما صرح دوله القانون
ونائب عن دوله القانون بانهم كان تقديم
استراتيجيه لعدم تطبيق الماده مائه
واربعين واه الشيعه قاموا لمده عشر سنوات
حيلوله دون تطبيق اذا يعني كل هذه
الاستراتيجيات كانت جزء من النظام السياسي
بالعراق يعني هذا لا يتعلق بالدور الكردي
هذه المساله الاولى المساله الثانيه
الاستقلال طلب الاستقلال وحق لاحد يتهم
الاكراد انهم السبب لكن عندما تكون مصائب
قوم عند قوم فوائد وهذا يسمى استغلال
بظروف صعبه التوقيت خاطئ كما قال المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض اليوم هذا ما سالتك عن
ال
المساله اعلان الاستقلال او حق تقرير
المصير اه من قبل رئاسه الاقليم اه قبل ما
يقارب من خمسه اشهر يعني قبل احداث اه
احداث الموصل بكثير وحتى كانت هناك بيانات
يعني اه بيانات متبادله من قبل الحكومه
العراقيه ومن قبل الرئاسه الاقليم حول اه
حقيقه الكرد في تقرير مصير فيما يتعلق
بهذه الامور وحتى انه اه قول السيد
البرزاني اه ل اه اه مساله قطع الميزانيه
عن اقليم كان بمثابه اعلان حرب على
الاقليم وهذا يتطلب على الاقليم وبرلمان
اقليم كردستان اه اصدار موقف جدي فيما
يتعلق بحق تقرير المصير يعني هذه الامور
ليست حديثه يعني ال ما توصلنا اليه الان
هي النتيجه وليس وضع كارثه طبيعيه كما اه
نستطيع القول انها ليست كارثه طبيعيه لم
تكن خارج اراده العراقيين اه حتى نقول
بانه لا يمكن ان نستغل هذه الموقف ومن ثم
اه نعلن استقلالنا في وقت اخر لا هذه جزء
يعني نتيجه لسياسات كانت موجوده ومن ثم
الى مرحله من الصعب جدا ان نتفق مع الاخوه
في بغداد حول اليات بناء اعاده بناء
الدوله العراقيه الحديثه ومن الشرق
والدخول في شراكه حقيقيه لبناء الدوله
يعني هذه نتيجه وليس استقلال المرحله هذه
المساله المساله الثانيه حتى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكثير من الدول العالم
حتى تركيا من ناحيه من ناحيه الموقف
الرسمي هم يقولون باننا مع الحفاظ على
وحده الاراضي العراقيه لكن هذه جزء من
التصريحات الرسميه هذا لا يتعلق ب اه
الاستراتيجيات والمصالح التي تاتي بها بعد
تفككت الدوله العراقيه ومن ثم هناك اليات
للتعامل معها سواء حفظ مصالح اه الدول
الاقليميه من جهه ومن ثم التعامل مع الدول
العالم سواء كانت الولايات المتحده او
الدول الاخرى والتعاون في مساله محاربه
الارهاب يعني في الحقيقه القادمه اذا جزء
من منظومه داخليه يتعلق بالسياسات
الداخليه وايضا السياسات الاقليميه
المواطنين يبقى يبقى انه دستوريا لا يحق
لانسان العراق الانفصال لانه دستوريا
يعتبر يعتبر العراق اقليما اتحاديا فباي
حق يعني يتجاهلون الماده مائه واربعين تحت
ذريعه ان المالكي فشل وان الماده لم يعد
لها وجود وخاصه انه في مطامع كثيره تتعلق
بال نفط كركوك
لا دي باقليم كردستان ديباجه تقل يمكن
يعني دماج الدستور العراقي لعام الفين
وخمسه واضح جدا واصر الكرد في ان يضعوا في
فتره هذه الفقره تقول ان الحفاظ على وحده
الدوله العراقيه اراضي الدوله العراقيه
والنظام السياسي بالعراق والشعب العراقي
مرهون لتطبيق هذا الدستور وهذا ما الها
الكرد بوضع اذا دراجه الدستور العراقي
القربي مساله حق تقرير المصير
اذا اه ت ال ال ال الحكومه العراقيه
طيب سيد
كيف توازن تركيا بين
مصالحها النفطيه مع البرزاني وكردستان
العراق وبين انها هل يناسبها هي ان تشكل
ما يسمى بدوله كرديه
هذا هذا السؤال
تركيا
وموقف تركيا هو موقف واضح تماما تركيا
تقول اننا نريد عراقا موحدا وتركيا لا
تريد تفكك العراق كما هو موقف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لكن على ايه حال السؤال
الاكثر اهميه هو هل ان العراق سيستطيع
البقاء موحدا ام لا تركيا والسيد وعندما
جاء سيد نتشرف ان برزاني الى انقره تركيا
قدمت اعلانا مشتركا يدعو لاقامه حكومه
وحده وطنيه في بغداد وهذا امر تم الاتفاق
عليه بين السيد رجب طيب اردوغان ورئيس
وزراء تركيا والسيد نتشرف ان بارزاني لكن
الفكره تبقى كيف يمكن ان نبقى على العراق
موحدا مع حكومه جديده ربما من دون المالكي
لان المالكي هو سببه بسبب تفكك العراق لان
سياساته اه ابعدت السنه وهم
وايضا ادى بهم الى
التعاون والتنسيق مع عناصر سنيه متطرفه في
واقع الحال نحن نشعر ان يجب ان تكون
العراق حكومه وحده وطنيه تعيد البلد الى
مساره الطبيعي لكن انت تعرف ايضا ان لو
كان هذا ممكنا وربما يكون مستحيلا حقيقه
لان المرحله التي بلغناها الان تميل لصالح
العراق بدلا من بقائه موحدا اذا وفقا لهذه
السياسه ما ستفعله ام بالطبع سواء ان شاءت
ذلك ام ابت هو ان توافق على تطلعات وامال
الشعب الكردي هم اخواننا وا ربنا وانقره
تقول هذا منذ مده طويله تقول ان هؤلاء ان
ال الاكراد العراق هم اقارب اكراد تركيا
اذا اذا ما شاؤوا ولو كان في النهايه لا
مناص من ابقاء العراقي المتحده الاكراد
سيعلنون استقلالهم ومن ثم انقره سواء شعب
ذلك ما بس تقبل به اذن نتوقف الان مع فاصل
قصير
وسوف نناقش بعده الاثار المترتبه داخليا
واقليميا على مطالبه البرزاني بالتحضير
لاجراء استفتاء حول تقرير المصير ابقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش طلب رئيس اقليم كردستان العراق
مسعود البرزاني من برلمان الاقليم بوضع
قانون مفوضيه مستقله خاصه للانتخابات من
اجل الاعداد لاجراء استفتاء على تقرير
مصير المنطقه اه سيد خسره هل هل بعد كلام
البرزاني بان من لا يؤيد اه لا يدعمونا
لكنهم ليسوا اعدائنا من الدول وايضا لدينا
دعم دولي في قضيه تقرير مصير الاكراد هل
يعني بان لقاءه مع كيف
ما تحدث به كبرى علنا والموقف الامريكي
اليوم علنا يختلف عن ما قالوه للبرزاني
وقتها
اه لا طبعا يتطابق ما قاله
للسيد الرئيس الاقليم بان ما اشاروا اليه
في السابق بان هذا الموقف الامريكي كان
ثابت اه اه الولايات المتحده مع اه وحده
الاراضي العراقيه ووحده الشعب والحكومه
العراقيه ولكن اه هل ان الولايات المتحده
ستقوم ب اجراءات معينه اذا ما اعلن الكرد
واعلن الشعب الكردستاني استقلاله واه اه
قرر اه مصيره بنفسه يعني هل هناك اجراءات
محدده تقوم به الولايات المتحده للحيلوله
دون هذا الامر او القضاء على الدوله
الكليه الوليده هذا من غير الممكن ان ال
ال ال التوقع في ال في المستقبل لان
الولايات المتحده سوف لن تعارض هذه الدوله
واه ربما لن تؤيد في في المرحله الاولى
المسار الدولي هي الدول الاوروبيه الدول
الاوروبيه الدولي
الدعم الدولي الدول بل الدول الاوروبيه ال
اه كما نعلم بان حكومه اقليم كردستان قامت
ومنذ عام الفين وثمانيه وقبل هذه الفتره ب
اه ب اه تعريف العالم جينوسايد الذي تعرض
له الشعب الكردي فيما يتعلق بال انفا لو
حلبشا والاسلحه الكيمياويه وهذه واقرت بعض
الدول الاوروبيه برلمانات بعض الدول
الاوروبيه هذا ال جينوسايد او البلاد
الجماعيه لذا اتصور انه كثير من الدول
الاوروبيه الان متعاطفه مع اقليم كردستان
واي اه اعلان للاستقلال سيشهد
ثم تاييدا لهذه الدوله ولا الاعتراف هذا
لا يعني بان الدول العربيه او الدول
الاقليميه كلها ستتعرض تعترف بالدوله
الكرديه الوليده لكن بصوره عامه الذي لا
يؤيد الدوله سوف لن يعارضه ولن يقوم
باجراءات معينه لمحاربه الدوله اذن هذه من
الامور المهمه يعني هذه التحولات السياسيه
في الشرق الاوسط اه البيئه الدوليه الان
هي مهياه ل اه اعلان الاستقلال و مهياه
لاعلان الدوله الكرديه بصوره بصوره عامه
لكن اه اه ربما سنشهد يعني كما قال
الاستاذ من انقره انه اه هل يعني هذا اننا
سيكون سن سنكون بمامن عن ان تطورات الوضع
على الارض في العراق وفي سوريا ال الحرب
الدائره اه هل ستطال هذه الحرب ام لا
اعتقد باننا سنكون جزء من الحرب الموجوده
لكن بصوره عامه اه اه ضمان اقليم كردستان
وامان اقليم كردستان سيكون باعلان ال اه
الدوله المستقله وليس البقاء في اطار
الدوله العراقيه والانخراط في هذه الحرب
الطائفيه الشعواء التي تدور الان اه في
سوريا وفي العراق بصوره عامه فاعتقد انه
الجزء من ال من من من الرغبه الكرديه في
الانفصال ياتي ب ب اه ب اه النهي عن
الدخول في حرب طائفيه موجوده او تستعر في
الشرق الاوسط بسرعه
اقليم كردستان بتركيا شمالا قد يعني اه
تفتي التجربه ال اه الكرديه في العراق
تفتح ال الاكراد في تركيا هل هل تركيا اه
تقبل بذلك الا تخشى من تكرار التجربه
لديها وان يطلبوا الاستقلال تماما وتصبح
قلاقل في الدوله التركيه
لا اعتقد ابدا ان هذه السنه الكون
الكيفيه التي ستؤول اليها الامور اليوم هو
مثير للاهتمام ان مرشحا للرئاسه في تركيا
سيد صلاه دميرتاش كردي
الرئيس
حزب الله
وهو كردي وهو واحد من ثلاثه مرشحين
يخوضون معركه الرئاسه التركيه ايضا اكراد
تركيا يريدون ان يبقوا ضمن تركيا وان يكون
جزءا من هذا البلد الكبير الذي يتطور
والذي اصبح
ساطعا في سماء
تركيا ما رايك بايران شرقا وسوريا غرب عن
اكراد ايران وسوريا
الوضع السوري
مختلف تماما لان ما نتحدث عنه اليوم هو
ليس فقط تفكك العراق ولكننا ايضا نتحدث عن
تفكك سوريا هي الاخرى وقد نرى دولا جديده
تظهر في الشرق الاوسط
على الاراضي العراقيه والسوريه
مستنده الى الطائفيه سنه وشيعه و مسلمين
وعرب وما الى ذلك ربما يكون الانقسام على
هذا الاساس وظهور هذه الدول الجديده
والاكراد سيكون جزءا من هذا الاكراد
السوريون
قد يكونون جزءا من كردستان لكنني لست
متاكدا من وضع الاكراد في ايران لان ايران
لديها سيطره قويه على افرادها وربما قد
تكون هناك رغبات
للانضمام الى جانب البرزاني لكن اكراد
سوريا ضمن هذا الاطار سوف يودون الانضمام
الى الدوله الفاصل اذا
اذا
طيب سيد خسروا السيناريو كما قدمه الى نور
شفيق هو تفكيك المنطقه منطقه كلها بالنظر
الى ما يجري تحدث عن الاكراد سوريا
بالتحديد واه انتم مثلا في اربيل لديكم
عقود نفطيه مع اسرائيل وواضح المطامع
الاسرائيليه في المنطقه وهنالك من يتحدث
عن مؤامرات اه تشارك فيها اسرائيل وربما
امريكا لتفكيك المنطقه واستغلال ما يحدث
هناك ايضا تخريب اتهام بتخريب على المالكي
مصالحته مع السنه هنالك تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وخطره كل ذلك الا يعني في هذا
التوقيت بالتحديد الا تخشى اربيل ان تتحمل
مسؤوليه المساهمه في تفكيك المنطقه كلها
وليس فقط العراق يعني تكون اللبنه الاولى
في في العراق وفي كردستان
لا طبعا الاقل يمكن ان لم يقل للنظام
السوري بان يستخدم الاسلحه الكيميائيه ضد
الشعب السوري ولم يستخدم ولم يقوم بانشاء
الداعش او الدوله الاسلاميه ولم يقوم بدعم
الجماعات المسلحه او الجهاديه في العالم
العربي ولم ي يشير الى السيد المالكي بان
يقوم ب سياسه التهميش يه للسنه حتى يصلوا
لهذا الامر حقيقه يعني العالم العربي
لا تتعلق بالنظريه
السيد المالكي كانت خاطئه جدا
الدوله الكرديه
لا
لا طبعا للمنطقه بدات يعني والمنطقه في
مرحله حرجه جدا اعتقد انه يحتاج الى تعاون
دولي واقليمي فيما يتعلق بالتصدي الكثير
من الامور التي ستحدث في المستقبل لكن فقط
تنميه انه لا توجد هناك عقود نفطيه بين
اقليم كل انسان واه اسرائيل ولا توجد هناك
بيع مباشر للنفط اه الى اسرائيل هذه امر
من الامور ال ال ال الضروريه الاشاره
اليها حتى انه
الاعرجي في عام الفين وثلاثه اشهر بالضبط
لها طبعا ام الفين وثلاثه عشر قدم وثائق
الى السيد الشهر الثاني بان النفط العراقي
يصل الى اه اه الى اسرائيل عن طريق شركات
وسيطه يعني وهذا النفط اللي تقوم بها سومو
يعني
هذه مساله حقيقه لا تتعلق بمساله التعاون
الاسرائيلي اه مهما كانت سواء كان عن طريق
سومو عن طريق اقليم كردستان الغير ممكن
التعامل مع هذه القضايا ومتابعه النفط
العراقي والنظر
اسرائيل اولا لكن بصوره عامه
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الحكيم خسر الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وصلت فكرتك حدثنا من
اربيل ومن انقره الى ان ورفيق الكاتب
الصحفي اه شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا جزيلا
لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
ام